qu' un
anim bien sympa là de discuter là mais
il y a un gars là gars respect je dis
donc on va redescendre de deux étages
dis ça commence à me courir sur le haric
vert moi je moi j'ai trouvé qu'ils vous
ont manqué de respect personn moi je
trouvais que c'était beaucoup moins bien
quand tu diriges pas le truc vous serais
pas
un un doit être
subtile ouais c'est ça voilà pour
l'instant pas subtile personne ne susera
euh merci vous avez vu cette histoire là
de l'avion là aux États-Unis euh t
c'était c'était où d'ailleurs aux
États-Unis Gill c'était euh il a atter à
l'ouest des États-Unis Michigan Oregon
Californie à l'origan portortland
portlandig c'est ce qu'il y a dans les
pizzas Portland en Oregon c'est le
l'État qui est audessus de la califor
raconter l'histoire ça c'est fou il y a
un avion en fait c'est Alaska Airlines
ouais je les déjà
des esquim qui c'est une très bonne
compagnie ouais je sais bah ou c'est
pour partir en
Alaska pas seulement ils font le tu peux
le prendre pour faire un Paris
perpignon Washington Portland par
exemple ok alors il y a un il y a un
hublo pas un hublo il y a un hublo oui
par qu'on fait pas la liaison le H le H
il
estover on a le droit maintenant
direover exactement on peut dire des
arovers maintenant ça vient de tomber
c'est tombé il y a 5 6 ans j'ai
c'est moi qui j' étais ça décorche ah si
ça écorche les haricots verts ça écorche
pas l'ORE j'adore moi des haricots vert
je préfère manger 100 fois des haricots
verts que des haricots verts je suis
désolé non mais c'est vrai d'ailleurs
qui mange des haricot verts ici je
déteste ça je déteste légumes quoi tu as
peur des fils toi parce que
traverict un fil je ah ouais toi
avec tout ce que tu as tu es encore
vivant sur vie fou c'est miracul mais je
mange pas
d'aricovert mais frère elle aou
d'icovert elle est encore mais a 200 ans
est en 2024 des trucs de partout frère
un truc de fou elle est là elle va tous
nous enterrer je connais les gens comme
ça je te jure que c'est vrai celle
franchement c'est un truc de ouf non
mais j'ai une liste c'est tout dealiment
à éviter la roquette enfin des ch tu
meurs de pas la prendre dans la gueule
he non non tu as quoi c'est quoi la
roquette encore bah oui tout ce qui est
comme ça salade frisée tout ça c'est et
fromage fromage qui s'étire aussi là
c'est à la racletteah la raclette je je
peux me suicider à la raclette non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'esten trs
drôleagin pas de Daniel al s'est suicidé
à la raquette la semaine
dernière un coup dur on l'a perdu là
siconner je peux te dire c'est un truc
de fou quoi non mais c'est fou ah ouais
donc tu peux faire une purée de haricot
vert comme ça
ça
pas je te jure je vais dire au chien de
te
mordre allez on va voir donc ce qui
s'est passé avec cet avion en fait il y
a une porte il y a un H qui s'est envolé
une porte qui s'est détachée moi
j'aimerais bien savoir là je suis sûr
qu'il y en a pas un ici qui ouvrir sa
gueule dans l'avion parce que tout le
monde fait des beau là il y a la porte
que moi j'arrive laisse-moi faire
donnez-moi parachute je me
[Rires]
barre un immense soulagement etqu
applaudissements à l'air libre sans
cette porte cet avion d'Alaska Airlines
se pose à Portland 1 heure après avoir
décollé l'issue de ce cours s'est envolé
à près de 4000 m d'altitude la chance
entre guillemets qu'ils ont eu c'est
qu'ils étaient en monté donc en monté
tout est sécurisé tout est rangé et tout
le monde est assis attaché de crash se
sont produit en 2018 et 2019
heureusement cette fois cet incident
n'aura fait aucun blessé ouais km près
ils étaient tous
aspirés leur chance c'est qu'ils étaient
pas assez haut encore mais à 2 km PRS
c'est jean-fanen qui m'a dit ça tout à
l'heure c'est des avions très
particuliers en fait c'est les 700
Boeing 739 max 9 et sur certains cette
porte là normalement elle est condamnée
et on a et par-dessus on a collé en fait
une autre porte avec un hublot et c'est
ce et apparemment il manquait des
boulons aurit mal serti des boulons
apparemment c'est ils ont trouvé la
porte et aujourd'hui ils ont retrouvé un
téléphone qui est tombé de l'avion
intact il y a un gars dans son jardin il
a retrouvé un téléphone ils ont vu qu'
l'avion à 5000
[Rires]
m franement c'est une belle info si si
c'était passé la même chose à 8000 ou
9000 m d'altitude les
gens comment au niveau de la
mémoire ni de la mémo la première
question que tu poses en en regardant ce
ça c'est de savoir pourquoi les gens
sont pas été expulsés de
l'avioné écoutes ce qu' ce modè nexiste
pas en
Europe mod
max99 priv on s'atte
pas que toi et il y a un étudiant qui a
perdu sa chemise c'est une info Jack ah
ouais ou il y a un seul portable et a
une chemise qui sont passé pardessus ah
mais c'est fou quand même comme tu vas
la racheter la
chemise raconter une dinguerie qui
m'arrivé en avion un vrai truc bien sûr
dumb Dumber donc en fait il y a un an
j'ai emmené ma meuf en weekend à New
York et j'avais pris des billets d'avion
un peu cher donc devant l'avion non tout
devant l'avion tu as pris la First ouais
j'ai pris
voilà il a qu la porte souv pas c'était
à 2 an C au début de la relation ah
c'était quand noill oui exactement
dépensé mon argent et donc on atterrit
cé à Paris New York on atterrit à New
York sur 5h du matin et vous savez il y
a le Seward qui vient vous réveiller
personnellement et donc il dit bonjour
monsieur Janton ils je don un petit jus
d'orange pour vous réveiller par contre
je suis désolé vous allez pas pouvoir
sortir de l'avion on a un tout petit
problème en fait il y a quelqu'un qui
est mort derrière vous il y a un mec qui
est mort dans l'avion et en fait quand
quelqu'un décède non c'est pas une
blague et il il le metett soit dans les
toilettes soit il le laisse dans les
couloirs entre les deux et donc le FBI
est rentré dans l'avion si on n pas pu
sortir en premier et le FBI est rentré
ils ont sorti le mec tu as pu vérifier
si c'est un ex de
Daniel c une personne é c une personneée
c'est horrible s décon c'est vra
franchement c'est ouf ouf cardiaque tu
voisouais c'est c'est quand je devais te
rejoindre à New York exactement et je ai
dit tu es là cy vous avez répondu non
frérot c'est que cétait magnifique ça le
gars il tu es là non frérot tout
simplement le gars est mort audessus de
la mer parce que si quand tu sais que le
gars est mort dans un avion tu dois
atterrir d'urgence au premier aéroport
que tu que tuis c'est une deuxième
info mer i tu es sorti avec un steart
toi
ça tu vois non c'est vrai non mais c'est
vrai sil a celui-ci bon les chériis non
CIT sympa vous avez c'est fou he l'avion
moi c'est ce qui me fait le plus peur à
l'avion parce que l'avion tu peux rien
faire vous avez peur en avion exactement
ça ouais j'ai non vous n'avez jamais
peur ouai bien sûr moins en
jet très mauvaise depu
bet vas-y molo les Van je te donne un
conseil vas-y molo l'avion tu peux rien
faire-ce que tu peux faire l'AV qu'est-
tu peux faire ouais tuattends tuattends
et tu dis ben voilà tu veux que je te
dis en bateau vous avez pas peur en
bateau en
[Rires]
y c'est pas ça la ça bouge moins
raconter un truc un jour ah ah pourquoi
un J le raconter actuellement je peux
pas le raconter actuellement pourquoi je
peux pas le raconter actuellement et
pour en 2024 vous allez nous raconter
oui pour en 2024 tu le raconterai là je
peux pas quel est le thème qu'est-ce qui
vous freine le thème le bateau de B
d'accord qu'est-ce qui vous retient de
nous le raconter là la pudeur
l'amour fermez vos gueules merci vous me
faites chier